benjamin perrin semble garder un bien
mauvais souvenir de son dernier dossier
en tant qu'avocat du premier ministre
c'est lui qui a joué les intermédiaires
entre son chef de cabinet n'a joe wright
et l'avocate de mac de fille pour
convaincre ce dernier de rembourser le
sénat or ils croient qu'on l'a tenu dans
l'ignorance
c'était une situation dit il dans
laquelle je me sentais pris au dépourvu
najet ne lui a pas rapporté par exemple
toutes ses conversations avec mcdo fille
même si benjamin péret n'échangeaient au
même moment plusieurs courriels par jour
avec l'avocat du sénateur il n'a jamais
parlé directement au premier ministre
dans ce dossier et a présumé par exemple
que stephen harper connaissait le plan
détaillé en cinq points qui prévoyait
entre autres que le parti allait payer
pour le sénateur car monsieur rhin est
un cri en ahl feu vert at il raconté en
témoignage je pensais que le premier
ministre lui même avait directement à
prouver il a exprimé ses frustrations à
nigel wright et aurait voulu pouvoir
donner dossier à un autre avocat comme
avocat dans cette affaire on m'a
clairement tenu à l'écart at il dit
mon client ne m'informe est pas des
discussions avec l'autre partie ce n'est
pas la façon de mener un dossier légal
après avoir affirmé sous serment jeudi
que contrairement à ce que soutient
l'entourage du chef conservateur riz
novak l'actuel chef de cabinet de
stephen harper connaissait l'existence
du fameux chèque de 90 mille dollars
cette portion du témoignage met au jour
un nouvel aspect de la crise
un autre témoignage qui vient brouiller
la campagne conservatrice alors qu'à
l'instar du npd les libéraux réclament
eux aussi une nouvelle enquête de la grc
et malgré ce sondage qui dit que plus de
60 % des canadiens ne croient plus le
premier ministre stephen harper lui ne
déroge pas de son discours après
d'hébergement pérennes un autre ex
employé du bureau du premier ministre
doit prendre la barre
chris wilcox était responsable de la
gestion des enjeux durant la crise son
témoignage commence lundi
et si daniel thibault radio canada à
ottawa